now to an update on the two paramedics
charged with murder in the death of a
man in Illinois last month body cam
video of the encounter you may have
already seen it erased serious questions
and concerns about their response to
this emergency Peggy Finley and Peter
cadigan are due to face a judge this
morning in connection with the death of
the man that's 35-year-old Earl Moore Jr
as Charlie Demar reports both sides say
that the police body cam video supports
their case
Moore Jr's family is vowing to make sure
the paramedics charged with his death
are held accountable they treated my son
like he was an animal
he was human Thursday their legal team
including civil rights attorney Ben
Crump filed a wrongful death suit
against Peggy Finley Peter cadigan and
their employer LifeStar Ambulance
Service all right it was the same day
the paramedics appeared in court by
video link from jail on charges of
first-degree murder
police body camera video captured Finley
and cadigan responding to Moore's Home
last month after he called 9-1-1 himself
sit up now
I am not playing with you tonight
sit up
there we go they're accused of killing
the 35 year old by strapping him so
tightly face down on a stretcher that he
suffocated when you look at that video
the reason is so shocking is because
they offer Earl no consideration the
video speaks for itself but findlay's
attorney W Scott hankin says the video
proves his client did not commit a crime
it's tragic a lot of tragic things
happen like they are not necessarily
criminal and this is one of them Edward
unsel is representing cadigan I don't
see where the probable cause uh exists
that a crime has occurred but ordinarily
even even when you have such a tragedy
as the death of Mr Moore ordinarily the
venue for these would be as Krampus
filed as a wrongful death case
we're told by a defense attorney
involved in this case that if
prosecutors don't play that body camera
video in court today that the defense
likely will as for that wrongful death
lawsuit we have reached out repeatedly
to the private Ambulance Company
LifeStar for a comment and have yet to
hear back both Finley and cadigan they
both remain Behind Bars each on a
million dollars Bond Michelle
all right Charlie thank you